dans ce boyau bonsoir vous êtes l'homme
du long terme même très long terme on va
en parler
quelques mots sur le très court terme
exemple à l'instant gérald darmanin
versus audrey pulvar la plainte plus la
plainte la rencontre et cetera c'est de
l'action ou c'est de l'agitation ne
mettez pas dans des situations comme ça
parce que je j'ai un principe qui est de
pas trop dire du mal des gens et encore
moins des gens qui sont dans dans la
majorité ou dans le courant majoritaire
donc vous en auriez un peu envie non je
pense que c'est tout le monde a compris
que c'est pas de cette manière là qu'on
doit exprimer des idées politiques et
encore moins des jugements politiques
il ya tout l'arène politique pour
défendre des positions et des principes
pour nous c'est très amusant le ministre
qui est week quelques minutes après le
passage sur deux devrait pleuvoir sur
lci très bien pour la politique est ce
que c'est bien alors un que ce soit
amusant pour vous journalistes c'est une
chose que j'arrive à comprendre mais
c'est pas ainsi que fini l'histoire
c'est pas dans l'amusement des
journalistes dont je pense que le vous
savez bien qu'elle ait la pression du
moment la pression de l'instantané vous
êtes une chaîne qui vit de la plage du
port et donc la pression est très
importante
je pense que les politiques doivent y
résister 1
ils ne résistent pas assez monsieur
d'hermann n'y résident pas être
n'essayez pas vous allez qu'il ne
prendrait pas ce piège des ministres
aussi en campagne aux régionales on voit
combien les moeurs changent c'est est
d'usagé communistes se présente avec un
risque s'il perd il doit démissionner
maintenant du nom il peut y aller tant
pis est ce que c'est normal lorsque des
élections locales
j'aurais souhaité qu'elles fussent
encore plus locales qu'elles ne le sont
pense que la france a une faiblesse qui
est de nationaliser tous les scrutins
vous qui êtes suisse vous savez
exactement qu'on peut avoir des débats
l'eau
aux mêmes des majorités locales qui ne
se décale kpa sur une majorité nationale
et vous un plus la situation politique
ça veut dire car donc envoyé genève la
suisse fait n'y a pas de majorité comme
ça envoyait plusieurs ministres ça
nationalise non je pense qu ils ont
voulu montrer qu'elles étaient leurs
engagements dans la majorité je vais pas
leur en faire reproche mais deux
j'aimerais un jour arriver à vivre dans
un pays qui aient une vie démocratique
suffisamment riche pour qu'on ne soit
pas obligé de nationaliser toutes les
élections locales
vous avez des débats vous avez des
enjeux qui sont des enjeux régionaux des
enjeux municipaux et vous n'allez pas en
faire le décalque j'ai toujours refusé
de faire une majorité locale qui soit le
décalque de la majorité nationale ou de
l'opposition nationale on va parler des
régions la vie des régions qui vous
tiennent à coeur quelques mots encore
sur l'hyper centre emmanuel macron
l'homme que vous avez soutenu il ya
quatre ans cette alliance très forte
vous l'avez vu évoluer
le contraste est saisissant moussa fait
bientôt 40 ans vous avez été dupe la
première fois lui ça fait quatre ans 40
ans quatre ans en quatre ans est-ce
qu'il a changé oui beaucoup
en quoi il suffit de regarder son visage
à vous êtes des médias de l'image vous
regarder le visage et vous voyez sur son
visage que le choc de la réalité les
chocs qui l'ont atteint plus qu'aucun de
ses prédécesseurs les gilet jaune
notamment il en parle dans l'interview à
zadig aujourd'hui un gilet jaune ça a
été un choc notamment ça a été un choc
mais vous savez le gt l'autre jour dans
un magasin à pau y avait
des vendeuses très sympathique autour de
moi qui m'ont dit monsieur bayrou vous
le voyez vous monsieur macron a souvent
dit oui ça va arriver disait écoutez
vous allez leur dire quelque chose de
notre part c'est plutôt louis plutôt lui
que nous parce que ce qu'il a affronté
on voudrait pas être à sa place
votre mouvement le camp démocrate a
montré un peu d'humeur sur un certain
nombre de sujets ces derniers temps sur
le pass sanitaire qu'on n'ait pas voulu
voter en première lecture sur la
proportionnelle promesses non tenues et
ce qui est une déception
non d'abord pour l'instant l'incident
dont vous parlez sein de textes d'état
d'urgence sanitaire il a duré deux
heures va être tout être en mauvaise
humeur de dodge admettons en fait ce que
vous êtes d une mauvaise humeur pour des
raisons fondées et la deuxième chose la
proportionnelle que vous évoquez je sais
bien que tout le monde considère affirme
urbi et orbi que c'est une affaire pliée
moi je ne suis pas de cet avis je pense
que c'est un combat absolument essentiel
pour comprendre de quel outil
disposons-nous si l'on considère qu'il
faut trouver un nouvel équilibre un
meilleur équilibre entre la fonction
présidentielle et la représentation du
pays
de quels outils aucun si on veut
continuer comme ça on est sûr que les
mêmes causes produiront les mêmes effets
et ma conviction à moi c'est qu'il ya
une chose très simple à faire
c'est décidé que dans une assemblée
nationale qui représente le pays tous
les grands courants du pays seront
représentés
on en est selon lui un équilibre vous
parlez d'un pouvoir plus décentralisée à
tout point de vue on en est si loin
aujourd'hui on a l'impression contraire
que non seulement dans la lettre et dans
l'esprit tout est très centralisé au
fond au cerveau emmanuel maintenant un
hôte cerveau alexis colère son
secrétaire-général l'elysée souvent
l'impression que cette relation un peu
richelieu père joseph et tout ce sont
les deux personnes qui ont toutes en
tête c'est très central oui
ça pourrait donner cette image là mais
ça serait centralisée si c'était
efficace
ce que je reproche à l'état aujourd'hui
c'est pas tant d'être centralisée que
d'être inefficace haute administration
vie gouvernementale et vous avez
l'impression qu' aucun des problèmes que
le pays a découvert diagnostiqué depuis
des années ne se trouve règle et vous
savez que j'ai je suis beaucoup
intervenu par exemple sur le fait de
l'effondrement de notre appareil
productif industriel agricole de service
et on se retrouve en queue de classement
sur un très grand nombre de sujets où
nous pourrions exister
vous pourrez faire campagne sur ces
sujets notamment on va développer
certains de ses sujets de fond mais au
moins encore sur emmanuel macron
l'avenir la candidature à la
présidentielle ça peut être qu'en
janvier
c'est d'abord lui qui doit décider s'il
se représente ou pas et se représentera
évidemment écoutez vous avez des
certitudes la question je vous laisse
vos certitudes
moi j'ai vous savez je suis frappé d'une
maladie très bizarre que je n'ai jamais
aucun souvenir des conversations que
j'ai avec le président de la république
sait c'est une amnésie récurrentes comme
on dit mais c'est à lui de panda
décision et après de regarder la manière
dont s'organise le temps politique
la france va présider l'union européenne
à partir du 1er janvier le
responsabilité très importante elle va
être concomitante avec l'élection
présidentielle je sais pas si vous
mesurer l'ampleur des sujets qu'il faut
saisie en plan c'est dire oui en tout
cas c'est ça donne une une bonne échelle
qui permet de mesurer la dimension de la
fonction et l'engagement de celui qui
qui s'y investit françois bayrou parlons
du temps long et même très long bien
plus loin 2022 c'est la natalité de la
france le déclin démographique alors
c'est votre grande une de vos grandes
propositions faire davantage d'enfants
regardons les chiffres qui résument tout
hein c'est la fécondité en moyenne on
était à un peu plus de deux enfants par
femme en 2010
on est maintenant à peu près autour de
1,8
là le minimum pour renouveler la
population qu'est ce que c'est ces 2 1
donc on est passé en dessous ces deux on
est passé en dessous énorme événement et
settat et c'est un signe très inquiétant
pour la france parce que la france était
le pays d'europe vous le savez bien
qu'ils avaient la natalité la plus
dynamique et ceci est un problème très
important parce que il ya un élément
auquel on n'attache pas d'importance et
qui est vital c'est qu'en france tous
nos systèmes de solidarité tous nos
systèmes sociaux et tous nos systèmes de
services publics sont fondés sur les
actifs
il faut les payer il faut se livrer des
impôts et ceux qui cotisent pour les
assurances sociales
alors si on regardait jouer dans si vous
avez une population qui se restreint
forcément les services publics et les
assurances sociales
la solidarité vont se restreindre aussi
que ça or la france c'est pas possible
ce que la france un pays qui est fondée
sur 7 sur ce contrat social pour payer
les retraites pour payer ce système est
ce que qu'on le veuille ou non c'est pas
l'immigration qui sera la seule ce nom
tout à l'heure dans votre introduction
vous avez dit françois bayrou dit que
non à la question que vous posez est-ce
que l'immigration
peut-être la réponse à cet effort
cette baisse est peut-être à cet
effondrement la réponse est non pour
deux sortes de raisons la première
raison est arithmétique il ya à peu près
entre 8 et 10 millions de femmes qui
sont en âge d'avoir des enfants en
france
si on voulait y adjoindre un nombre
suffisant de personnes d'origine
étrangère ce que vous vous rendez compte
de la dimension des du nombre de
personnes qu'il faudrait introduire ça
n'a pas de sens
arithmétiquement et c'est dangereux
culturellement
parce que si vous organisez un choc de
deux entre communautés diverses savez
les allemands l'ont fait en une fois un
jour l'introduire l'alliance en 2015
madame merkel on se rappelle c'est celle
qui est laid avec la avec les mains
seulement madame merkel trois mois ou
quatre mois avant la décision de madame
merkel je crois me souvenir que le
patronat allemand a dit il nous faut un
million de personnes supplémentaires
c'est eux qu'il le voulait le pâtre
darryl on lui demande le gouvernement
décide on a fait entrer un million de
personnes en une seule année 1 et je
crois qu'une telle expérience d pas
renouvelable françois bayrou quand même
quand on regarde la réalité nos
confrères de deux actifs actuels ont
montré à quel point
quand on regarde les comptes c'est très
spectaculaire l'europe voilà non pas
détaillée mais c'est très compliqué mais
la petite courbe en bleu tout en bas
c'est ce que serait l'accroissement
naturel sans l'immigration dans l'union
européenne
on voit à quel point la société se
métisse de fait est ce que là on se
voile pas la face notre société en train
de se métisser ce métis sera toujours
plus est ce que ça n'est pas le cas elle
se métisse depuis où elle se se
pluralise elle se il ya des mélanges
d'origine et de population depuis des
siècles et elle c'est pas la gloire s'y
est classé beaucoup plus raison je
prends mon exemple moi je suis moitié
iranien j'étais dans une classe d'école
il ya un certain nombre d'années j'étais
très exotique à l'époque aujourd'hui ça
c'est complètement déplacé
il n'y a pas que des inconvénients à
tout ça le le fait qu'on puisse avoir
des rencontres de culture de communautés
différentes de manière de voir la vie
différent pour moi c'est aussi ça peut y
avoir des aspects positifs les
nationalistes les nationalistes pardon
appelle ça le grand remplacement c'est
leur langage
est-ce que c'est faux selon vous je
pense oui je pense qu'en soient ses mots
je pense que c'est faux parce que
numériquement ça n'est pas vrai en
france le nombre d'immigrés qui rentrent
tous les ans est un des plus faibles des
pays qui nous entourent mais c'est pas
ça la question
si vous voulez réfléchir une seconde si
vous donnez à une population qui a son
histoire son identité sa culture le
sentiment que demain ces enfants ne
vivront plus dans le même pays n'auront
pas les mêmes repères culturels
alors vous déstabiliser profondément ces
pays
est-ce que pardon ce changement n'a pas
déjà vu tout à l'heure on regarde et de
votre photo de classe qui est des signes
de vie et des sites de fans de françois
bayrou dire comment il suffit de pas mal
à regarder ça ça marchait pas ou vous
êtes sur la photo vous venez me dire le
deuxième au premier rang en partant de
la gauche voir mon chef d'édition pardon
je kavtidze et on vous reconnaît aux
oreilles n'ya pas de mal un parent n'a
absolument et je dis non
au contraire j'oubliais enfin alors vite
vacances qu'il ya des réflexions encore
dire sur ce sujet mais sans sens du tout
il s'agit pas de caricaturer mais ce
cette photo-là ce monde là de fait et ce
qu'il a changé oui c'est davantage
métissé aujourd'hui culturellement à
tout point de vue est ce qu'on n'est pas
en train de sous-estimer complètement
cette réalité là c'est une réalité avec
laquelle nous allons devoir vivre le
nombre de familles dans les gens que je
connais dans le monde
pyrénéen rural le nombre de familles qui
étaient très à cran sur ces questions de
rencontre de deux couples de mariage de
ils ont évolué et ben quand ils ont vu
leur fille épouser quelqu'un d'une
origine complètement différente parfois
d'une religion différente où leur fils
avoir ainsi un couple qui soit un couple
biculturel bas il découvre tout d'un
coup qu'il y a des richesses aussi là
dedans ça peut marcher mais vous savez
très bien que beaucoup de gens pensent
que non ça amène aussi des problèmes qu
est ce que vous dites amérique zemmour
qui dit à moins de prénoms français
qu'est ce que vous dites et à la dame
qui dit à montpellier il ya plus pierre
en pierre il ya plus de pierre en
réalité il est beaucoup de gens qui
trouvent ça exclusivement ya plus de
pierre nulle part si je vous disais les
prénoms de mes petits en jouant alors
vous auriez de sérieuses surpris mais on
sait que c'est comme ça les histoires
des prénoms il ya des vagues
j'ai toujours pensé que si j'avais une
ou plusieurs vies j'aurais fait une vie
de sociologues et j'aurais étudier cette
question
moi je suis fasciné par ça vous avez des
familles des couples qui se quand ils
apprennent que l'enfant arrive se creuse
la tête pendant des mois pour trouver un
prénom original et tout le monde choisit
le même alors chez vous il ya au moins
j'ai regardé vous avez six enfants dont
calixte mais c'est tellement d'autres
persos perdu combien de petits enfants
c'est un secret professionnel n'ont même
plus de 20 je crois un peu en séries
alors ça c'est la formulation d'accord
mais on voit bien à quel point c'est
difficile quoi
à noter pour moi d'accord comme si vous
le conseillez vous savez très bien qu'en
réalité force et la natalité c'est quasi
impossible il ya des gens de droite qui
vous disent autorités y ait des gens de
gauche qui disent les crèches etc
en réalité ça marche jamais dès que les
gens atteignent un certain niveau social
ils font moins d'enfants
monsieur rouge bien je crois pas du tout
ça je pense que la clé
le secret est dans l'optimisme du pays
si on continue à avoir en effet un pays
démoralisés alors les pays démoralisé ne
font plus d'enfants parce qu'il vous en
font moins parce qu'ils ne peuvent pas
se projeter dans l'avenir et donc cette
cette question de dynamisme nationale
c'est aussi la question du dynamisme
démographique mais on peut y aider
il se trouve que si vous regardiez la
courbe de la natalité française
le jour où on a coupé les allocations à
un certain nombre de français sous le
quinquennat de françois hollande ça sert
effondré et donc il ya aussi des
responsabilités avoir des crèches ou des
assistantes maternelles garantir aux
femmes qui ont des enfants que ça n'aura
pas une conséquence négative sur leur
carrière
très souvent ce n'est pas le cas faire
en sorte que les pères de familles
puissent prendre des responsabilités au
fond faire en sorte qu'ils aient une
attitude compréhensive de soutien de la
société
ça c'est une vraie clé ans environ plus
de natalité on voit que chez vous ça ça
tient à coeur est-ce que c'est aussi on
parlait alors de sensibilité démocrate
chrétienne chrétienne ça fait partie de
ça pour vous alors je j'essaie de ne
jamais mélanger les problèmes civiques
et les problèmes de conviction
spirituelle personnelle c'est pas un
secret que je suis croyant et que même
je suis
comme on dit pratiquants mais je ne ne
mélange pas ces sujets le sujet du
dynamisme démographique de la france et
n'est pas est un sujet civique d'un
sujet démocratique
c'est notre encore une fois ce qui est
en jeu c est ce que nous allons garder
le contrat social le plus généreux au
monde que nous avons ou est-ce qu'il va
s'effondrer
est-ce qu'on accepte qu'il s'effondre
est-ce qu'on accepte
autrement dit de baisser sans cesse dans
la reconnaissance des nations mon avis à
moi c'est qu'il est une responsabilité
générale de pouvoir aller dans le sens
de ce dynamisme et il ya une preuve là
une chose qu'on peut qu'on doit prendre
en compte pour retrouver l'optimisme
dont je parle
quand on fait des enquêtes d'opinion
pour demander aux femmes ou aux couples
combien d'enfants il voudrait la réponse
est généralement 3 alors qu'ils en ont
moins de 2 et donc il ya ya
vous voyez bien ce que je veux dire il
ya une attente est-ce qu'on peut
soutenir cette attente pour assurer en
face de cette attente je trouve que
c'est le devoir
allons-y d'un pays ce soir vous dites oh
cook à l'élan jeudi les 20h40 un mythe
fait trois enfants et plus était le vrai
qu'ils sont franchement je dis pas ce
genre de choses parce que je sais que
c'est un sujet qui peut prêter à sourire
mais je dis pas ce genre de choses parce
que le la décision d'avoir des enfants
est une décision qui est située
précisément au carrefour du plus intime
de l'ain team et de l'enjeu de société
et je ne mélange pas l'un et l'autre ce
que je constate c'est que les femmes ou
les couples voudrait avoir
en moyen d'un enfant de plus que ce
qu'ils ont et dont les avoirs françois
bayrou quelques mots de vous avez 70 ans
hier je disais 40 ans de vie politique
70 ans yann barthès quotidien vous
valait un peu chambré là-dessus
s'alléger j'ai beaucoup rajeuni parce
que à bon beaucoup d'un seul coup parce
que jusqu'à récemment j'avais six ans de
moins que le président des états unis et
maintenant j'ai 9 ans de moins que le
président des états unis tout est
relatif par adam qui lançait sais plus
non mais je veux bien que les grands
dirigeants de la planète
quel âge ont-ils aujourd'hui sont l'âge
de l'expérience vous prenez poutine vous
prenez sea shipping vous prenez
évidemment
joe biden et vous voyez que les peuples
assez souvent ont besoin aussi
d'expérience en france nous avons la
chance d'avoir un président jeune et
autour de lui les gens qui on te en
effet de nos capacités une expérience je
trouve que c'est plutôt bien
et quant à moi je me sens d'une
juvénilité que j'ai rarement rencontrées
dans ma vie alors longue vie à vous le
temps qui passe quand même a pris un
sens particulier avec la mort d'une
personne c'est marielle de sarnez qui
était comme une soeur pour vous en
politique il ya peu c'est très rare en
politique des gens qui à leur mort
recueil sur d'unanimité comme ça dans
l'hommage pour vous ça a été un cap
7 c'est un moment de bascule de choses
très importantes
vous perdez quelqu'un avec qui vous avez
partagé 35 ans de devis et d'engagement
et avec ti tous les jours dix fois par
jour ou qu'un soin par jour vous
examiniez les choses et les questions
ben oui évidemment c'est un c'est un
manque mais ce manque que là pour moi
d'abord il s'efface pas j'ai perdu aussi
mon bras droit à pau qui disparut la
morue vieux moindre la mort de votre
père précoce la mort de plusieurs
personnes doutent femme une manière
accidentelle ou et c'est elle et elle
était là elle était là elle est là et
elle donne son sens à la vie et des gens
qui pensent que la mort c'est quelque
chose qui fini pour moi non moi je pense
que les gens qui
ont disparu d'une certaine manière ils
sont là et peut-être on pourrait dire
d'une manière certaine ils sont là et
ils sont non seulement présent mais pour
moi agissant alors évidemment ça ça crée
des liens sont pas des liens tout à fait
ordinaire parce que c'est des liens dont
la présence n'est pas sans si vous
croyez à leur intervention âge et oui
j'ai toujours pensé j'ai toujours
vérifier dans ma vie vous parle et
événements tragiques très très précoce
dans ma vie j'ai toujours pensé qu'en
effet il était là et qu'il pouvait aider
ces deux grands mystères parce que c'est
très difficile à comprendre
j'ai toujours pensé que la mort c'était
pas la disparition c'était la sortie du
temps nous nous sommes dans le temps
vous et moi surtout vous avez le chrono
qui tourne nous nous sommes dans le
temps et où tout d'un coup ils ont
acquis un autre mode d'existence de jouf
et là des confidences personnelles qui
sont pas très habituel sur des plateaux
de télévision
françois bayrou un mot de conclusion il
recevait stéphane bancel l'homme de
modern à ne pas vous faire reparler de
votre mais lui était dyslexique
vous étiez bègue oui et lui disait très
bien à quel point ça va être une force
pour lui en fait de surmonter sa
dyslexie
vous êtes d'une espèce différente vous
les bègues les dyslexiques vraiment il
ya une forme de ses pattes bien en tout
cas je sais que c'est c'est moins
agréable à vivre que sané a raconté
après coup par les observateurs c'est
une épreuve
en réalité on n'oublie jamais quand on a
été belle ou dyslexiques j'annonce que
je pense que c'est ineffaçable et je
pense que c'est bien que ça soit
ineffaçable parce que ça vous met tout
d'un coup en relation avec les gens à
qui il arrive de méchantes bricole dans
la vie à qui il arrive des accidents
avec les gens dont on se moque pas ce
que ça joue un très grand rôle vous
aviez été moquée beaucoup forcément
comment voulez vous qu'il en soit
autrement vous connaissez quelque chose
de plus cruel qu'une cour de récréation
vous vous garantis qui a rien de plus
cruel parce que c'est comme ça c'est
comme dans la meute des des petits des
p'tits loups un coeur on se mordille et
donc c'est oui c'est c'est franchement
pas sympa comme comment dire et et en
même temps ça vous conduit à quelque
chose qui est de retrouver l'enfant que
vous étiez et peut-être de l'apprivoiser
un peu voyez ce que je veux dire
ça remonte encore ouzou s'est on en
guérit tout pourra jamais où il y avait
toujours quelque chose
je pense qu'on n'en guérit jamais mais
on paraît en guérir c'est déjà pas si
mal
merci beaucoup françois vaillant vous
l'avoir était notre invité en direct
merci beaucoup